I talked about this last week briefly we
have a new team koko tablet app that
were actually quite proud of
we're very self hating at this show we
criticize everything we do but this Team
Coco app is real it's dishes you know
that's 80 oh yeah that's right okay
we're very well-balanced okay all right
when I'm on my meds but this is it
really is an incredible app it was
designed by our digital team it's
fantastic and we like it so much we
actually made a video to tell people
about it we thought we'd show it tonight
hello I'm Colonel Brian I purchased this
jacket online from a North Korean
magician and seeing it now on camera I
would read it up until this moment your
life has had little meaning but I'm here
to change all that because I'm here to
present the incredible team Koko Tabata
I hope you're ready for the future
because the future is sure ready for the
you
you can interact with friends and other
fans while behind the scenes photos
trivia and more appear right at your
fingertips this app has access to time
travel portals NASA doesn't want you to
know you can use the team cocoa tablet
app with any recent episode of Conan
I smell innovation and onion mustard did
someone make a sandwich on this the team
cocoa tablet app also has all the
on-demand code and video clips
slideshows and blog updates you could
ever want there you have the team cocoa
tablet app it's better than you
it doesn't light amazing things that
we'll take a break